since starting the Diary of a CO one of
the most popular questions I get asked
is what are your favorite episodes and
what are your favorite guests now I
don't think about it in terms of that I
think about moments and insights so in
this episode we're going to do something
a little bit different I'm going to show
you four moments from the Diary of a CEO
that genuinely changed my life and
changed how I think about one of my core
beliefs that I then actioned that made
my life better
[Music]
in your book that little voice in your
head is this concept of neuroplasticity
oh it says it on the back of the book it
says
um retrain your brain for maximum
happiness this concept that we can
retrain our brain physiologically seems
like
nonsense and I can't change my arm
so when someone you know asserts that
you can actually change your brain you
can change your arm I can change my arm
of course what tattoo no you work out
that's true when you work out you're
building muscles in your arms and that
same exact process is exactly what
happens inside our brains and it's
called neuroplasticity the only
difference is that you don't see it you
don't see it visibly you can see your
muscles growing because that's the
function that they need you know they
need to grow to perform but in your
brain what actually happens again like
computers it's almost as if you loaded a
new piece of software I need a new piece
of operating system uh on on your brain
literally for every one of us listening
uh everyone listening to us to it right
now at the end of this conversation
their brain will be why are they
differently than when it started every
single instance of anything that you do
literally rewires the hardware itself
the neurons that fire together wire
together okay so imagine the old days of
the switchboard okay and
um you know Steve wants to call his mom
so you you know crank your phone and the
operator says uh you know hi how can I
help you and you say can you please
connect me to that number and she would
literally take a wire and Patch you and
your mom's phones together okay after a
while the operator constantly every time
you call you want you ask for your mom
so the operator goes like why am I even
wasting my time on this let me just
patch that wire to his mom all the time
okay so that's exactly what happens in
our brains if you if you perform a sin
give a certain function your brain
starts to build networks that make that
function easier to perform in the future
if you do it one time it becomes a
little easier if you do it 20 times it
becomes permanent okay and there are
there are tons of studies that if you if
you take a simple task like tapping your
finger on the table okay and you're
requested to do that say 20 times every
hour after a few days you'll find that
you're so much better at tapping your
finger on the table and you can do it
much faster you can do it consistently
and you can do it in the background
Gamers know that for certain okay the
problem with neuroplasticity is if you
tell your brain to wire for tapping your
finger it will if you tell it to wire
for solving complex mathematical
equations it may take a little longer
but it will if you tell it to wire for
hating people it will become very good
at hating if you tell it to wire for
fearing the end of the world because of
what the media is telling you it's going
to become very good at feeding the world
I know some of these people I have no
absolutely and you don't want them in
your life the challenge of our modern
world is that we think that this brain
is supposed to be there to make us
successful
yeah okay first of all it's not the
primary function of the brain the
primary function of the brain is to make
you safe okay and then the secondary
function that we push human as humans to
that brain to do is to invent iPhones
and create podcasts and have amazing
things right that's a secondary function
but believe it or not before that
secondary function your your brain is
supposed to make you happy
because happy is the ultimate form for
you to perform in life if you're not
happy you're not as effective as you
could be at achieving survival
think about it huh if you're grumpy all
the time at work people don't like you
you're not focused uh no one wants to
help you you're wasting most of your
time your brain Cycles uh you know
thinking about the negative and so
you're not Innovative or creative and so
on and so forth it degrades your
performance happy is a better place for
you to be at work because it will make
your customers want to do business with
you it will make your colleagues want to
uh you know to help you out it will make
your boss welcome you and their team and
so on and so forth we are social Animals
by definition and we want to have that
in our life and the easiest way to
connect and to open up and to is
discover the world is to be in a happy
place that's a primary function of your
brain
it's hard for some people you know
because we can all think of someone in
our Lives who has
um certain
wiring very stubborn wiring that almost
seems impossible to unwire and the only
thing we all have that ourselves as well
the Saturn wiring in our brains where
something happens and our reaction to
that thing might be uh you know to
catastrophize it's the end of the world
that's like a it feels like it's a
certain set of worrying where trigger
and then the brain goes through the
circuitry and it goes catastrophe Panic
yeah and yeah and the answer to that I
found was to actually guide that person
or yourself if that's yourself to the
opposite of your wiring so if my if my
wiring is to look at everything and see
what's wrong with it I should
deliberately force my brain to look for
what's right with it so uh you know I uh
when I was when I was coming here it was
very busy in the morning and so I came
late if you remember and my brain's
immediate reaction is oh what's gonna
happen I'm gonna be late for Steve right
that's the immediate reaction of the
brain because something is wrong so it
looks for what's wrong
I could also say and what is good about
that what is good about being a little
late you know he's been recording for
the last few days so it may give him a
little bit of extra time do you want to
know the truth I was so happy you were
late because I was late right so I was
doing upstairs reading that I was
reading the book and I was thinking I
just hope he's like 15 minutes late
he's not coming here perfect so I
carried on going and carrying on going
and Karen I'm going and I just finished
as you arrived yeah so it's perfect time
you see that that is the truth huh
that's the truth that your brain tries
to deny you from seeing and
interestingly you can train your brain
so so basically what you can do is for
every thought for every negative thought
that your brain gives you task it with
the task of giving you a positive one or
two positive ones nine I say nine yeah
because in reality if you look at life
around you more than 90 of life is okay
for the your brain to contribute more
than that as negative is not fair
right so if literally if your brain says
hey by the way this studio is a little
warm what else is about the studio my
friend Steve is there the lighting is
perfect the crew is amazing the you know
the coffee is is not that bad you guys
get got me honey I can go on for hours
right and and the idea is by training
your brain to look for that what are you
actually doing you're firing the neurons
together prostitute so and exactly your
your your book basically says it is the
answer the answer is when you find
gratitude what what that gratitude
Journal that you keep ever that you kept
for years every day what was it telling
you it was training your brain to look
for what's right
that your brain every night that you did
it was like okay it seems he's gonna be
asking to call his mom a lot more often
it seems he's going to be asking for
good things a lot more often I might as
well observe them I might as well find
them and so yes
you said some people are impossible to
rewire they're impossible to rewire if
they've been practicing a certain wiring
for 21 years it's not going to take 21
seconds to rewire anyone including me
and you it will take 21 days let's say
for your brain to recognize I need
different work and it will take maybe 21
months for your brain to say and I don't
need the old wiring anymore okay and the
game here is can you actually keep doing
that can you keep tapping your finger in
a way that trains your brain that this
is the wiring that you need
like can I keep going to the gym and
working on my absolute guns yeah believe
it or not the research will tell you
that a big part of being athletic is
wiring of your brain not your muscles
for your brain to be able to say I will
go even if I feel a little tired I will
go even if I feel a little uh busy I
will go and I will do the right
exercises even if the last push is a
little painful a lot of people will hear
that and go what's the evidence for this
what's the evidence for neuroplasticity
is there science oh there is a ton of
science behind neuroplasticity any
anything from between neuroplasticity
and neurogenesis is when you know
neuroplasticity is to rewire
um the connections between the neurons
and neurogenesis is to actually create
new or new neurons when if you're hit
with a ball for example and part of your
brain is damaged how we can recreate
that right if you have a stroke and how
you create recreate that and ample
evidence one of the very famous stories
is Matthew Ricardo when we spoke about
him in the beginning Matthew's brain
looks different than the average human
brain his insula is much bigger in
relative comparison his prefrontal
cortexism is bigger and and it it fires
more often it's simply because of the
constant neuroplasticity of I need you
to meditate I need you to stay quiet I
need you I mean some of the of of of
Matthew's Journeys would last four years
in isolation I would meditate for four
years maybe be in isolation in Hermitage
for four years right and and so at that
level your brain starts to do very
different things and by the way that's
not unusual now many farmers around the
world live in isolation for a very long
time believe it or not you and I when we
when we spend a long time on airplanes I
I chose a long time ago to not watch a
lot of stuff on that on you know I maybe
watch one movie but not the entire trip
the other bits of Silence that's
actually a form of of meditation I uh
you know my my absolute wonderful friend
Jamie Nelson the photographer if you
know him he photographs indigenous
tribes and the way he does it is he
would go and
and spend a few months outside their
premises you know their Village if you
want in silence you know camping out
there he doesn't speak their language
he's just sitting there waiting for them
to accept him and then he would start to
you know communicate to them in sign
language because it doesn't speak their
language and he's one of the wisest
people I know and I and I said how did
you become this wise I never studied any
of those things and the reality is is
because he's in constant reflection and
meditation he's sitting out there and
he's spending hours and days in
reflection and meditation right because
you're sitting alone all of those things
are our habits and all of us have the
chance to do it I mean so you you could
be on the tube uh for a commute of 40
minutes a day and you could be in that
commute cursing life and that's a very
good 40-minute exercise to work and
another 40 minute going back or you
could be spending the 40 minutes in
gratitude you could be first for you
know uh
the 40 minutes listening to music could
be doing whatever what you will do for
40 minutes a day will rewire your brain
it really is like a paradigm shifting
thought that our brains are in this
constant growth and evolution but when
we look at as you said my muscles are my
muscles are changing State size growing
more fibers to achieve their objective
in a different way and of course my
brain is as well and when you think
about that it's really liberating
because you realize that you're not
stuck with who you are absolutely not so
let's choose what which parts of it are
we going to grow I think that's the
whole point and we grow it with our
actions and our thoughts repetitive
actions thoughts and memories believe it
or not one of the interesting things is
if you take a memory in the past yeah
and you think about it over and over and
over it's as if you're hap it's
happening over and over and you're
growing the neurons that are needed or
you're growing the connections between
the neurons that are needed to trigger
that memory think happy memories okay if
you sit next to your partner and focus
on one thing that they do and go like
they say do this they do this they do
this they do this and forget that they
do a hundred other things that you you
love and appreciate 8 your
neuroplasticity is making you completely
obsessed about that one thing and you
can only see that one thing and
eventually you know some of my friends
after a breakup I go like so what
happened then they'll say one thing it's
like just you could they obsess about it
over and over because your brain is
growing to say he needs to think about
this right I'm gonna make it easier to
think about this I'm gonna make it
faster
more accessible one of the things I've
heard you talk about a lot is your your
journey and your
evolving relationship with sex and
sexuality and how that changed from when
you were very young through the period
when you were drinking a lot
um till today can you talk to me about
that Evolution and what you've learned
about those topics
that might benefit me yes absolutely
so
I'm going to
sort of keep referring to my sobriety in
that period of my life because it was so
transformative
and it revealed so much to me so much
that I could have never imagined at the
time so something that also happened
when I got sober I think this was about
a year into my sobriety
I realized just how much sexual shame I
was holding so much of it and I
initially sort of wanted to fix it
wanted to do something about it what are
some surface level things that I can do
what can I read what can I sort of dive
into how can I deal with it from where I
am now as a 25 year old but I quickly
realized that I actually had to trace it
back to see where it even comes from and
I realized just like so many things it
did come from my childhood being raised
in a Christian home
I learned again not directly more so
indirectly that being a sexual being was
not something that was off God it was
not something that was supposed to be a
part of who I am pleasure was never
discussed sex was never discussed even
Intimacy in general I never saw my
parents hold hands I never saw my
parents hold hands I never saw them kiss
I never saw them hug I never saw any
sort of affection but I knew that they
loved each other I knew that they cared
about each other but affection and
intimacy I just never saw that not for a
moment when I sort of wanted to really
understand where a lot of the sexual
shame was stemming from or just
I'm also even outside of sex intimacy
intimacy feeling very disconnected to
other people when it came to intimacy
but also from myself
I realized that I could only be
expressive as a sexual being if I was
drunk or if I was high if I was in that
place where of course my inhibitions are
low but I had no insecurities I didn't
have to feel like I'm doing something
wrong I didn't have to feel like my
pleasure was wrong but then when I got
sober all of those things came to the
surface and then I I had to look that in
the eye so that also became something
that I started sharing over time as well
I was sort of sharing my journey with
sobriety I then started sharing the
things that were revealed as a byproduct
of me getting sober and sexual shame was
a huge one was a big part of that my
relationship with sex has evolved a lot
yeah over over time I think it was early
in my early years influenced by porn yes
for many people so me too that's the way
I went into the game trying to be those
those male porn stars right
and I think over time and I think
there's this wider issue in our society
specifically I've got to be honest with
men yes
um
what they think that what they think sex
is in terms of this kind of
very aggressive often dominating
transactional
um encounter yeah and then there's you
know again I'm just I'm just talking
freely I don't give a [ __ ] whatever
please do please but I'm seeing a lot in
my in my close friends they're all in
relate they're often in relationships
not all of them where they're having
problems with
their sexual relationship with their
partner they're basically saying things
to me and I'd say this is crazy I'd say
75 to 80 of my male friends are saying
my partner doesn't want to have sex she
doesn't like having sex yeah and I was
there at one point too my partner said
that to me at 1.2 yeah and I took it on
face value I thought they don't like sex
what I came to learn
is that wasn't true but that what what
I'd learned to be sex and what I was
bringing as sex this kind of aggressive
you know whatever
was not yes the language that they spoke
right and I feel like I'm surrounded by
men that need to start seeing sex as a
language because then you can ask
yourself well actually she's speaking
Spanish and I'm speaking English that's
why it's not she doesn't like English
she just doesn't she speaks a different
language yeah I mean yes that's a lot
I'm just dumping that on YouTube no that
resonates so and I'm I'm really glad
that you said this because I think
you're speaking something that is on so
many people's minds or something that
they've just never really put language
to and a big part of my
Awakening if you will and really
addressing that sexual shame is because
I also learned sex from porn at 10 years
old 10 years old so by the time that I
had sex for the first time when I was 14
it was very much like a porn performance
to put it very simply and I speak to so
many people men and women about this
very specific thing a lot of us learn
that we should perform that sex should
be driven by orgasm and ejaculation and
this sort of production if you will
which is not actually accurate for most
people when it comes to what really
actually feels pleasurable especially
for women so I started to realize when I
got sober that every time that I was
having sex for example I faked every
single orgasm it was all a perform I
didn't know much about my body because
I'd learned from porn and because the
men that I was with had also learned
from porn we were just in a performance
and no one's actually talking about it
right so in time times when I was in
relationships and I made myself think I
don't want to have sex I don't want to
have sex anymore it actually was not
that I didn't want to have this type of
pornified sex that's what I actually
meant so what you just said is really
important and I realized that's when I
found tantric sex actually yeah that's
when I found tantric sex around 2018
because I realized that I had always
felt like sex was being done to me yes
that I was not a part of it and that is
how most women feel I I felt like I
needed to apologize
yeah because that's what that's what I
came to learn yeah was that the the
reason why the person I was with had
turned around to me and said I don't
like having sex is and when we got
talking about it after I acted like I
mean let me be clear the first time she
said that I did not understand my little
Neanderthal monkey brain went uh like I
was emasculated by it yeah it made me
feel what is this something that I was I
didn't know
ended up breaking up but this person got
back with this person a year later
when I was maybe a bit more mature I
apologized and I said I want to have a
conversation and I also said to her that
I'm going to be here regardless of
whether we have sex or not yes and then
she could she had a safe enough space to
start talking to me about it and what I
discovered is she'd been with
should I had three previous boyfriends
over the course of seven years
her view of sex was this person comes
and takes from you treats you like this
object and he was with him for five
years treats you like an object takes
what they want from you and then he was
actually going and cheating on her as
well right so Not only was he taking he
was then like hurting her and that cycle
just repeated her relationship with what
sex is was really really toxic she
didn't like that yes she didn't want
that anymore yes and that's what she and
me probably referred to as this word sex
so it was kind of like learning a new
language of sex and what it actually is
that meant she went from the place of
like I don't have sex anymore
to absolutely loving to have sex yeah I
didn't think it was possible I thought
if they don't like sex dump them yes you
know I'm gonna go find someone else
right that will let me take yes and you
know what you you've articulated that so
beautifully in terms of
sex being a language and it's going to
look different for every single person
because something that I realized is
that I could tell when I was with a man
sexually I could tell if they were sort
of
if it was like a script almost like a
play-by-play like this is exactly the
method we do this we do that switch into
this switch into that it wasn't sort of
flowing and very intuitive as to what's
actually needed in that moment which
reminded me of porn and I would also
realize actually and this is something
that I've spoken about so much because I
ended up um starting a sexual wellness
company called Cherry Revolution over
time
and I realized that even some of the
positions I would get in
were very much like porn because certain
positions in porn are like that because
the camera is there not because it's
comfortable because that's the shot for
the viewer to be able to see it so when
I started to see that I'm starting to
replicate this in my most intimate
private moments but we're both doing it
I made myself believe that I didn't
enjoy sex so then drinking and drugs and
everything that came with it I felt like
those were the moments that I could be
fully expressive without needing to
perform which is very interesting
because you would think it would be the
opposite that I would then perform more
but I felt as if I could actually speak
my mind if I didn't enjoy something can
we try this can I do this instead or I
just want to give or I just want to
receive can we be slower and then when I
was sober I felt like I couldn't say
those things because if I say to you as
my partner I might be emasculating you I
might be embarrassing you you might
think something is wrong so I would just
perform and you're performing as well
and then it just causes a huge
disconnect so tantric sex was the first
thing that I came across that made me
realize and really articulated that sex
is actually not a specific destination
did you know that you can actually enjoy
sex without uh ejaculation that you can
have a full body orgasm that you can be
very slow that foreplay can be the main
thing that you do that you can
experience orgasm without penetration
just so many different ways of
articulating that experience of sex and
it's just that an experience
and that changed so much for me it's
such a sort of a narrative violation for
so many people who've spent their whole
life watching porn and then yeah
recreating it this idea that you can
have an orgasm from touch
that you can use energy to to cause
someone yeah orgasmic pleasure and yeah
um
yeah I just that's it's a really
important topic that I think people need
to talk about a lot more and I think
just just saying to someone that's
listening to this that might be in a
relationship where they're not they're
in a sexless relationship yes just
proposing the idea that what if you both
just speak there's just say there was
ten languages what if you're just
speaking the wrong language right you
know what I mean and what approach would
you then take you're probably trying to
learn the language yes yes and also
communicate to them what language you
speak and see and see how you can be
bilingual I guess yeah you know what it
it reminds me of um are you familiar
with Love Languages and and that that
whole thing yes I realized that a lot of
people
expect someone to give in the way that
they like to receive you know so no one
really says okay how do you like to
receive love how do you like to give
love and the moment that I started
asking those questions even though I
believe I [ __ ] cringed in the
beginning I'm like really if I get it
but you get used to it yeah and if they
run off good food yeah it's Stephen it's
been a game changer to just ask the
person that I'm dating or my current
partner to be like how do you like to be
loved how do you like to receive love
and how do you like to give it
um because just those simple questions
can change so much and then you can use
the same with sex what do you like and
what do you not like what have you
changed your mind about what do you like
to do now and again or maybe not so much
sometimes
um how much time do you need how does
your arousal actually work and I know
that some people might not know how to
answer these questions for themselves so
it's actually very good to start asking
yourself those questions before was
speaking about it with someone else
because I think we get into
relationships and make so many
assumptions based on all individual
experiences and our world view and we
expect the person we're with to reflect
the exact same thing back to us but we
don't we don't ask questions
I watched a lot of interviews of you
before you you arrived here today and I
think in pretty much all of them you
said I'm a normal guy I'm a regular guy
and I get that I get that I understand
what you're saying however well it's not
false modesty I don't want to I'm not
going to let people build builds me into
something I'm not you know and I think
as I get older I know the frailties more
and more and I'm not ashamed of them you
know I mean it's it's okay many mistakes
many many sort of it's okay otherwise
Things become all too
you know that how it's it's hard to
relate to you know but you you got
through SAS selection just I got through
all this [ __ ] just you know and people
turned turned to you and said things and
as they turn back and quit right that
that for me is a filtering process of
something yeah whatever that something
is resilient all it is is something we
can control it's not a filtering of
talent it's not filtering if you're
you're brilliant you're through you're
not through you know it's a genius of
selection for the Special Forces it's
all about heart and spirit and we can
all have that that's not a god-given
talent that's a that's a muscle that
builds with walking through the door of
failure time and time again and keep
getting back up you know so I like that
as why I say I'm an ordinary person as
well also say just to so many things
because you know yes I passed oh yes you
reached the top of this man or yes you
do but it's always just and that's okay
you know and it's also Often by standing
on the shoulders of many Giants who've
helped me you know many many times you
know if I think of ss selection you know
that time there were so many times where
somebody somebody just kind of believed
me in a critical time you know it might
be something where the two corporals
running something good we want that guy
do on you know a bit of luck falls on
his side somebody backs you you know or
you know you you I don't know just the
more I look back on so many so-called
achievements the more I see
the hand of good people in critical
moments but as you know you have to win
the hearts of those people in the first
place but also the role of just that
dogged determination to keep going and
that's not
a thing of being brilliant it's just
trying to keep going often sliding
another step back but keep moving
forward
and you say that to you know I've got
three boys now three teenagers and I
think if you said to them what one thing
does your dad say to you day off day
before you go to school
it's always just
you know don't give up don't never give
up be kind you know be determined but
never give up and they roll their eyes
but you know what one day they'll know
that it's a key thing a key thing of
life you know you don't have to be the
best to do your best
did that resilience muscle as you call
it grow over time of course it's just
like like everything it's like the
little little Seas to the mighty Oaks
you know how do we build it just inch by
inch and uh and that's a great thing
because it's not something only some
people can have you know it's Universal
for us all we can all become people
think it's a god-given gift to someone
be resilient resilience is that muscle
and you build it by failing and trying
to stay positive and and trying to get
back your feet and going again you know
I look back and I remember being uh
really excited about being picked for
the fourth eleven football team as a
linesman I wasn't even in the team you
know and it was like my job was to bring
on the oranges at half time you know but
it was that and I remember my dad was
the only dad on the side of the pitch
cheering me on I thought it's so
embarrassing he's not I'm not even in
the team and dad said you know he's come
to kind of
but actually those little steps of like
I'm going to do this I'm going to bring
on those oranges and you know you're
never gonna forget it's gonna be great
and ink into tiny little things
but having to fight for things you know
it's how often do we see at school
though the the school hero
actually in life
doesn't always do that brilliantly and
why is that it's because they've got you
know schools rewarded that
they've never tested this
you know where little Johnny who doesn't
have that doesn't get the awards
is the linesman brings on the oranges
yeah whatever it is drugs doesn't even
get noticed and everyone's anything but
never gives up and keeps doing his best
and still doesn't really get noticed but
doesn't matter but when he leaves school
this might not be the biggest thing but
this is like ninja-like you know that
that resilience muscle inside is strong
and as you know and as I know in life
that's the one that is gonna carry you
further and and the Unseen people at
school often do better in life it's like
don't peek too early don't peek at 14. I
certainly didn't I sat here with um
Eubank I've been thinking about this
idea of resilience and what it really
means and as we sit here today my
current hypothesis is basically
resilience is the story it's kind of
this contract you have with yourself
this self-story about who you are and in
those moments when no one is looking I I
was talking to Eubank about me being on
the running machine and knowing I've got
two minutes to go because I said before
I started I'd run till 45 minutes but my
legs are hurting and they're cramping
and I could give up and walk away and No
One's Gonna know because no one's here
but what I I alter my own self story in
a way and I send a message to myself
that I am the type of person that gives
up when it's tough so is it really do
you relate to that and is this kind of
like you're crafting this story about
who you are to yourself with every small
decision you make doing the linesman job
you said I'm going to do it the best I
possibly can and although it's not what
I wanted I'm gonna I'm gonna give it
everything I can and not give up yeah
yeah does that relate and also I think
the thing of giving up is that you know
what is that thing a temporary pleasure
long term yeah that's not true you know
and and for me I just I I developed a
thing where
[Music]
whenever people quitting or complaining
I like those moments for me it was like
okay there's all the all the chat and
the bravado is always there at the
beginning I was full of that but bring
it down put the squeeze on you know we
like grapes and squeeze us you see
what's inside bring the squeeze bring
the squeeze now we see characters see
what people are like and for me it just
became whenever I saw people quitting or
complaining especially complaining you
see it so much just in the military you
see it on big Expeditions you see it
even when we're filming TV shows for
people you know when it gets hard you
know and you're hungry and you're scared
and you're up against it and you're
dehydrated you know those are the
moments and for me it just became a
trigger when everyone's complaining and
giving up it's a time to give more you
know just you don't have to give more in
the early times just wait till this and
that's how you separate yourselves in in
business and in life and in relationship
you know in the big moments you know
look at a relationship when it's when
you're under that wheel down everyone's
throwing it you know are you gonna
really throw that nasty comment or gonna
hold it and just try and be gracious and
kind in those big moments you know and
and I like that it wasn't
you know it wasn't complicated to think
about Under Pressure it was just like
when everything's going wrong that's
that I'd give more rather than give up
and I held on to that in many difficult
moments you know across many different
Arenas and um
and has helped me you know I remember
this guy said to me once said and you'd
do anything for another 10 seconds I
like that you know when it's you're in
that moment you keep going another 10
seconds
that makes you different though
you've got to admit because most people
don't want another 10 seconds yeah well
it hurt it hurts I'm not saying it's not
going to hurt it's going to hurt but
that fire inside it's in us all you know
it's just you've got to dig sometimes
but it's it's a great truth to know that
it's there when you dig you know it is
there and uh and I think as you say once
you get used to this and you start to
practice it the muscle gets stronger and
then you almost seek out tough types you
know this is a chance to to shine you
know and as you say that's how you
separate yourselves in life you know
you're going to reach these points but
but in those big are you going to go
this way how are you going to act in
those big moments and it's always what
separates you know reaching those
Summits for not reaching those Summits
when you look back on the person you are
now and the tremendous wisdom that
you've just demonstrated just speaking
to me just then
do you recognize
the Mel that was couldn't get out of bed
was feeling depressed couldn't find you
know described herself as you as you did
as being lazy do you recognize that
person and what's at the very essence in
the engine room that drove that change
was it
passion
was it finding your calling
um because I know you weren't this part
you couldn't have been this person oh
dude it's also been 31 years I mean come
on I've had I've like basically been
changing for as long as you've been
alive for crying out loud so true and
also human beings are designed to grow
but not everybody seems to because you
have they don't understand being stuck
yeah interesting see
being stuck is one of the most universal
feelings of The Human Experience and
nobody understands what it is
what is it oh it's amazing when you hear
this it's like
so remember how we've talked about how
uh the human beings have this crazy
amount of natural intelligence wired
into us and inside your body we've
talked about one of the signals anxiety
anxiety is a signal that means pay
attention
that's why you go into fight or flight
you're in an alert mode okay
that's all it is it's a signal an alarm
system and your body has a sophisticated
system of signals and alarms
and they're all tied to fundamental
needs
anxiety is tied to your fundamental need
for safety that's why it's a signal
let's talk about your most important
fundamental needs let's go right back to
psychology 101 Maslow's hierarchy of
needs
uh you need food or else you die
so when you need food what is the signal
that your body sends you when you need
water what is the signal cost when you
need
um a
air yeah you're catching your breath
when you need rest what do you feel
when you need connection what do you
feel lonely
human beings are designed to grow
when you stop growing what do you feel
stuck yeah I was gonna say stagnant but
I guess stuck is yeah or stagnant we're
still
trapped I guess is yeah
feeling stuck is a signal that you've
stopped growing
that's it
and when most people feel stuck since
they don't understand that it's tied to
a fundamental need for growth
we believe it's an existential crisis
and we blow up our lives
for most human beings what actually will
get you feeling like you're not stuck
is having something in the future that
you're looking forward to
or taking a class where you're learning
something or changing a routine so that
you try a new class at the gym learning
anything gets you back in touch with a
fundamental need it makes you start to
feel like things are moving and from
that place of feeling a little bit more
empowered
you'll be able to make better decisions
about what big things need to change in
your life
and is that you would also describe that
as a moment where your life has like an
absence of purpose
I think about I think about
various examples Olympians that come
back from the Olympics and they they're
like 80 chance of depression after
they've you know and then I think about
people who have lost purpose in their
lives for whatever reason been fired
from their jobs or whatever all people
that are in jobs that are uh you know
absent of purpose completely a feeling
of being stuck and and then you
certainly talk to us about the
importance of goals and Ambitions going
forward when humans don't have that
forward ambition or that thing to look
forward to in the future and their
current situation lacks purpose
they become very um psychologically
disorientated either way I'd describe it
um I act I have a different take on
purpose
um I think everybody's purpose is
exactly the same
I think your purpose
is to share your true self
to be fully seen
and for the Olympian when you are
training and you're in that Arena
that is an experience of being seen
and for most people that are lacking
purpose they feel profoundly invisible
and being seen
fundamentally comes back to whether or
not you even see yourself
and when you start to feel empowered and
you start to see yourself and meet you
where you are
what happens is every day that you're
able to stand with yourself to accept
where you are to give yourself the
compassion to give yourself the support
and the love and the respect and the
worthiness that you deserve you're going
to go out into the world and share more
of yourself that Olympic Athlete is
sharing more of themselves
and so I think our purpose in life is to
come back home to ourselves to reconnect
with ourselves and to empower ourselves
to go back out into the world and share
our stories and share our experiences
and share our full selves with the rest
of the world and look if I can save
anybody the heartache and the headaches
that cause myself
that's a life well lived
you know if I can laugh at myself along
the way if I can punch a wall and drink
a gin martini and then share with you
like okay this and then get out because
how I got out of that
because I could have been in that cycle
The Old Mill would have been there for a
month
everybody's out to get me I never get
recognized why even bother it doesn't
matter
and
it allows me to share in real time
that I feel all the [ __ ]
but I don't like to stay there and this
is not toxic positivity
it is important when you're disappointed
to allow yourself to feel disappointed
it is important when you lose something
to give yourself the grace to grieve for
as long as you need to it is important
to have a good cry to have a good scream
to draw it's important to feel the highs
and the lows you're meant to feel it all
but you can shorten
the length of time you stay down
and what always helps me is I just kept
saying what I what I've said
a couple times during this I I say to
myself
I refuse to believe
that if I'm a good person
and that if I'm working hard
I refuse to believe that this doesn't
work out
I refuse to believe that I'm not going
to be okay like I know
that This Moment's going to pass and I
know that I will look back on this
moment five years from now and I'll see
exactly what I was meant to learn and
redirecting your focus to what actually
matters
and the fact that you believe in your
heart that you got the mindset you got
the work ethic you got the ability to
figure this [ __ ] out and to keep going
and that eventually if you do what's
meant for you is going to find you you
will be rewarded for all this in the way
that you're meant to be rewarded
that's amazing it's an amazing feeling
because you can pick yourself up no
matter what happens I spent so long
being dysregulated
having a nervous system that was
constantly on edge like what it felt
like to be me
any moment in my life whether it was
sitting in a classroom or I was sitting
at that law firm bait stamping or I'm
sitting as a young mom with postpartum
depression or I'm sitting in yet another
job I don't like
is it felt like being in a car
at a stoplight that had a green signal
and the emergency brake was on and the
gas was floored and I was going nowhere
like just the engine revved and the
sense that I needed to go but not being
able to go
and
when I finally started to get control of
my own thinking
when I finally started to understand
anxiety and how to quiet it in my mind
and then how to quiet at my body when I
finally got serious about understanding
trauma
and healing it in my nervous system
first
through EMDR through therapy through
guided MDMA sessions
I finally had the experience
of being in my body
and being safe and being okay
and I hadn't had that in a really long
time and um
I'm so
aware of when I'm not in my body now I'm
so aware of when my nervous system
starts to go on edge
that my tolerance for staying there is
zero
because I live for far too long feeling
on edge anxious dysregulated
self-loathing that when I dip into that
space and everybody you dip into that
space once a day if not like I used to
live there and so when I start to dip
into that dysregulated anxious on edge
intense space
it's like get this out of my body we got
to get back into my new default which is
grounded centered in control of what I'm
thinking what I'm gonna do next
and it's a fluid situation
but you just gave me the insight as to
why it's so quick for me now
because I've made a commitment to myself
that after spending 30 years that way
40 almost that I don't want to live
another year that way another week that
way another full day that way now do I
have things that happen in my life that
are
tough that that put me into a mode where
I'm anxious and on edge and of course do
I disassociate when I get really awful
of course but I now have the tools
to bring myself back into my body
to give myself the encouragement the
Assurance the support that I need
so that I can face whatever is happening
and know that I'm not only going to be
okay
I'm actually going to be awesome
eventually
quick one as you might know crafted are
one of the sponsors of this podcast and
crafted are a jewelry brand and they
make really meaningful pieces of jewelry
the really wonderful thing about crafted
jewelry is it's super affordable it
looks amazing the pieces hold tremendous
meaning and they are really well made I
think I've worn this piece for almost a
year it hasn't broken hasn't changed
color because it's really really good
quality and it costs roughly 50 Quid
people will be surprised when they hear
that they'll probably assume that all of
my jewelry is like solid gold and cost
thousands and thousands of pounds but
what's the point when you can achieve
the exact same effect from a piece of
jewelry that's high quality and costs 50
Quid that's why I buy crafted quick one
for many years people have been asking
for a coffee flavored Hill and quite
recently he'll release the iced coffee
caramel flavor of their um ready to
drink heels and I've just become hooked
on it over the last couple of weeks I've
been on a really interesting Journey
with huel which I've described and
talked about a little bit on this
podcast I started with the berry ready
to drinks then I moved over to the
protein salted caramel because it's 100
calories and it gives you all of your
essential vitamins and minerals but also
gives you the 20 odd grams of protein
you need and now I'm balanced between
them both I drink mostly the banana
flavor ready to drink I've got really
into the iced coffee caramel flavor of
fuels ready to drink and now I'm
drinking that as well as the protein
make sure you try the new ready to drink
flavors that the caramel flavor is
amazing the new banana flavor as well is
amazing and obviously as I said the iced
coffee caramel flavor has been a real
Smash Hit so check it out let me know
what you think on social media I see all
of your tags and Instagram posts and
tweets about you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
my God
[Music]
[Music]